david -bonjour alors cette annonce elle
a été fait sur facebook hier par jérôme
rodriguez c'est l'aboutissement d'une
longue bataille judiciaire pour l'une de
ses figures inde et gilet jaune longue
bataille judiciaire c'est le mot olivier
temps cette affaire a traîné en longueur
petit rappel des faits dans un premier
temps nous sommes le 26 janvier 2019
lors d'un rassemblement et des gilles et
jo une place de la bastille le premier
policier explique avoir lancé sa grenade
gmd en direction du centre de la place
de sa propre initiative considérant être
encerclée par des manifestants hostiles
il avance même le terme légitime défense
le second policier lui le tireur de l bd
a tiré dans la foule et de se lancer de
grenade un geste décidé sans qu'on ordre
ne lui était donnée et à la suite de ces
tirs et bien jérôme rodrigues est
gravement blessé et perd l'usagé de son
oeil droit plusieurs mois après les
expertises médico balistique ont conclu
que jérôme rodriguez avait été atteint
par un palet de grenade
lgm dit mais cette blessure on se
souvient avait relancé le débat sur l'
arme lbd une arme controversée qui
auraient blessé au moins 30 manifestants
depuis les premières manifestations
ado gilet jaune et des mutilés que
justice qui souhaite que justice soit
faite et c'est justement surtout pour
cette raison que jérôme rodriguez s'est
dit ému hier dans son live facebook il
espère que cette enquête elle va faire
avancer les choses pour que la vérité
triomphe écoutez moi j'aimerais que vous
sachez une chose c'est que si un jour
meurent en justice j'aurais gagné qu'à
moitié parce que l'important c'est que
l'ensemble des mutilés du mouvement
l'ensemble des borniers l'ensemble des
copains qui ont perdu une main puisse
avoir justice que tous ceux qui sont
morts dans le mouvement
par la faute de la police puisse avoir
justice que tous ceux qui subissent des
coups et des violences de la police
puisse avoir justice et non pas que les
policiers les donneurs d'ordre ceux qui
aujourd'hui se permettent de faire taire
les contestataires
à coups de mutilation j'espère que ça va
se passer pour le mieux et j'espère que
cette décision fera date et permettra à
l'ensemble des mutilés de pouvoir voir
la même justice que moi en tous les cas
et c'est ce que je souhaite le plus au
monde
par cette décision mais justement david
pourquoi cette enquête a été si
compliqué et pour quelle raison il a
fallu deux ans pour obtenir une mise en
examen
bien c'est un problème en tout d'image
dans le rapport de l'igpn que nos
confrères elle de l'ops ont pu se
procurer les conclusions révèlent que
les enquêteurs n'ont pas pu utiliser les
vidéos alors qu ils l étaient déjà
obligatoires pour les forces de l'ordre
de fumée filmé et l'utilisation est d'un
élevé dès lors de manifestations le
policier en question est mais
l'hypothèse d'un dysfonctionnement de
l'appareil ou d'une erreur de
manipulation
il indique également qu'il était tombé
au moment de l'arrivée place de la
bastille et que la caméra avait alors pu
être a détérioré les enquêteurs
attendent donc de déterminer les faits
avec des photos un reportage photo avait
été effectué ce jour là par un policier
l igpn s'est fait remettre les 206 à
photographier mais a constaté que 23
d'entre elles avaient été susceptible
d'être d'avoir été effacés la raison le
policier explique qu'il effaçait
toujours ses photos ratées bref vous
l'aurez compris des manquements qui ont
fait durer dans la longueur cette
enquête l'igpn a conclu que le tireur de
grenades a fait preuve d'un usage
disproportionné de la force ou de la
contrainte avec une arme ou un moyen de
défense intermédiaire suivi de blessure
1 selon les termes exacts du rapport à
la qualification criminelle retenu
contre ce policier est passible de la
cour d'assises
en attendant ce jugement les deux
fonctionnaires ont été placés sous
contrôle judiciaire par les juges
d'instruction en charge de la faire
merci beaucoup david pour toutes ces
précisions